hallo ihr lieben eines der beliebtesten
fleischsorten beim grillen ist hähnchen
und ich persönlich liebe
hähnchenbrustfilet nicht nur so beim
mittagessen sondern auch eben auf dem
grill als spieße und oft hat man das
problem dass es eben trocken wird wenn
man das falsch zubereitet oder die
marinade einfach nicht gut genug ist und
ich zeige euch jetzt meine perfekte
grill marinade für hähnchenspieße hier
sind die zutaten
hier habe ich hähnchenbrustfilets die
habe ich schon in so große stücke
geschnitten etwas größer als
mundgerechte stücke außerdem für die
marinade joghurt ich habe hier 35
prozentigen naturjoghurt olivenöl
außerdem fein gehackten knoblauch salz
pfeffer gemahlenen kreuzkümmel edelsüß
paprikapulver und entweder den saft
einer halben zitrone oder den einer
ganzen die mette diese marinade könnt
ihr übrigens auch auf andere teile des
häkchens anwenden das heißt
hähnchenkeule oder flügel das geht auch
ich habe wie gesagt hähnchenbrust und
das problem ist einfach dass generell
beim hähnchen dass es etwas wärmer ist
und deswegen die das eben nicht so
saftig das heißt wir fügen jetzt das
fett hinzu in form von olivenöl
wer kein olivenöl man kann natürlich
auch neutrales öl sonnenblumen oder
rapsöl verbrennt aber ich liebe olivenöl
deswegen kommt das jetzt bei mir auf
jeden fall
und das gibt uns die ideen zum joghurt
so das öl ist jetzt im joghurt das ist
unsere basis und jetzt wissen wir dass
noch das heißt wir gehen jetzt doch
knoblauch und die vier anderen gewürze
rein und wer mag kann auch ein chili
schote nehmen und die ganz fein hacken
mit rein geben aber nur die ließ schaaf
mögen ich bin ein weichei da bin ich
ganz ehrlich ich geb dir jetzt mal ganz
schnell in die seite und gibt die
anderen zutaten betreiben sei
jetzt geben wir unseren limettensaft
rein wie gesagt unsere marinade braucht
etwas säure ihr könnt falls ihr das
alles nicht da habt auch gerne ein
spritzer essig und aber so schmeckt
einfach natürlicher und besser und jetzt
gehe ich hier noch mal an den tisch und
gehe dann nochmal trip ist so ein
bisschen haben so versteht das nie aber
so bekommt ihr einfach mehr saft raus
aus dem wasser raus
[Musik]
jetzt ist die marinade fertig hat er
wirklich nicht lange gedauert aber jetzt
kommt der trick jetzt müsst ihr das
richtig schön ein kneten und dafür nehme
ich jetzt handschuhe und das wichtige
ist regiert das reh kommt jetzt es ist
eben wichtig dass er das lange einziehen
ist es muss ganz lange marinieren ich
verarbeitet dass es am nächsten tag
weiter das heißt bei mir wird das jetzt
24 stunden mariniert ihr könnt auch
zwölf stunden oder halt über nacht aber
haltet die zeit all das heißt also
mindestens über nacht ist schon ein
ziehen lassen
ok ich wurde gerade überredet über
stimmt dass wir es doch ein bisschen
schärfer reingeben deswegen nehme ich
jetzt privat also paprika flocken
und da gibt es auch die schafe und die
milde variante jetzt haben wir die
schafe okay aber nur ein bisschen haben
wir ja faktor ich rein
das lasse ich jetzt vielleicht das
reicht das reicht
die marinierten hähnchen stücke werde
ich jetzt zu decken
und dann gehen sie in den kühlschrank
und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder so
ein tag später hähnchenbrustfilet konnte
jetzt richtig gut die marinade einziehen
jetzt müssen das ganze nur noch auf
spießen und dann grillen ich habe jetzt
hier diese spitze für den grill
ihr könnt entweder die benutzten oder
auch schlicht i service ein
zungenbrecher und sie für die spitze
habe ich noch keinen tipp für euch die
könnt ihr einfach fünf minuten lang im
wasser einweichen lassen dann verbrennt
wir euch nicht und ihr verbrennt euch
dann auch nicht die finger
[Musik]
meine hähnchenspieße sind jetzt alle
fertig und ich habe ungefähr zwölf stück
raus bekommen ich habe immer so sechs
bisschen auf einen spieß draufgelegt und
es riecht auch richtig lecker gerade in
der küche ich freue mich jetzt schon
richtig die zu grillen
hier noch mal ganz kurz ein paar tipps
wer mag kann zwischen des fleisches auch
noch gemüse reintun champignons
capparoni paprika tomaten ganz wie ihr
möchtet ich persönlich bin kein fan
davon weil ja alles unterschiedliche
garzeiten hat oder halbzeiten bis es
dann genießbar ist und deswegen mag ich
das mit fleisch pur
außerdem ein zweiter tipp ist dass er
das 20 minuten bevor ihr das geld aus
dem kühlschrank holt damit ihr das nicht
ganz kalt direkt auf den heißen grill
legt jetzt können wir aus so jetzt sind
wir hier am grill der ist schon an und
jetzt geben wir unsere hähnchenspieße
drauf und das geheimnis für saftige
hähnchenspieße liegt einfach darin dass
er sie nicht oft wendet es gibt es jetzt
einmal drauf dass sie so lange darauf
bis die seite durch und dann drehe ich
dass es auf die andere seite und so
weiter
[Musik]
übrigens ein kleiner tipp wenn euer
grill in der mitte sehr sehr heiß sein
sollte weil ihnen gerade erst an gemacht
habt dann verlegt die teile einfach nach
außen und da können sie dann langsam
garen
ihr kennt das eher wahrscheinlich dass
euch die spieße dann am grillrost
ankleben dass es ganz normal deshalb
lasst sie immer erst von einer seite
richtig schön grillen dann drehte sie um
und sobald dann alle seiten schön fest
sind von außen könnt ihr sie auch gerne
immer mal wieder wenden und dann könnt
ihr auch mal klug die plätze tauschen
dass es die die mehr hitze vertragen
die kommen die mitte und andersrum
[Musik]
und fertig sind unsere saftigen
hähnchenspieße ich mache sie am liebsten
so weil sie sind richtig schön weich im
innern und außerdem außen richtig schön
wird sich falls das ganze jetzt
nachmachen möchte schotten und die
infobox da stehen die genauen
mengenangaben ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim grillen bei diesem tollen
wetter und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr
beim nächsten mal auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]
zu guter letzt kommt noch ein bisschen
säure reihen in fehler wie gesagt in
form von zitronensaft oder limettensaft
habe dafür entscheiden
links oder rechts oben rechts
zitronensaft nein ich bin ihm enden
werden so anstrengend zu schrauben